[Música]
nosotros somos el dúo la jardinera me
acompaña mi amiga del alma elena zúñiga
y mi nombre es oscar jiménez vamos a
tocar una pieza que es una composición
mía se titula gran y para contarles una
curiosidad está esta melodía surgió en
el camino que sube al cerro gran en la
cordillera de talamanca la escuché
dentro de mi cabeza después cuando
llegué a mi casa la toqué en el charango
como para terminar la de descifrar y
cuando volvía a subir el cerro con un
guía que había escuchado la pieza íbamos
pasando por el mismo lugar donde yo lo
había escuchado y me dijo oscar cuando
usted me compartió la pieza yo me
imaginé pasando por este lugar y esa la
mano la magia que tiene en nuestras
montañas aquí en costa rica
esperamos que lo disfruten
no
[Música]
as
no
[Música]
bueno y hoy en este télex de educación
nosotros venimos yo y óscar óscar ellos
dos o tres nosotros vamos a tocar por el
derecho a la educación artística para
todas las personas como una necesidad
básica del ser humano de expresión
crecimiento de cultura de este país
vamos a tocar ahora una pieza mía bueno
el dúo la jardinera tocamos piezas de
ambos y eso nos gusta muchísimo y sin
querer no fue el propio compusimos obras
acerca de los cerdos de costa rica sin
ni siquiera decirnos el uno al otro lo
que habíamos hecho y esta canción que
sigue se llama cerdo dragón que está
dedicado al cerro dragón que está
ubicado en entre acosta y aserrí en la
provincia de san josé
[Música]
y él
amanecer
en mi cara
lucila
abandonado
ya no quiero
más razones
para estar tan
asustada
quiero ver
la caravana
dijo yo te
suyos a mí
que habitaron
de cierto
de atacama y si lo lee
la arena
pero no
[Música]
me voy
caminando
por senderos ocultos
donde se detiene el reloj voy abriendo
el paso
sola con el cielo y una nube de agua
no me importa cuánto tiempo me he
perdido
caminaré
caminaré lento ya no importa cuánto
tiempo me he perdido
caminaré
caminaré con el viento
yo
caminaré
caminaré por el cerro dragón
hasta acariciar el sol
[Música]
/ avis
delirantes
y los árboles
[Música]
y mi almohada
desbordada
de violetas
perfumadas
la frescura
yo
me besaba
para
[Música]
y las locas
mariposas
simularon a esta área
[Música]
y la arena
i
no
o
muy mal
u
[Música]
caminaré
caminar por el ser dragón
hasta acariciar el sol
[Música]
y